we're also monitoring the vaccination
statutes all across the state christian
casadas joining us now live in studio
with how our community is doing when it
comes to the cobid battle christian well
denise you mentioned how nevada and
clark county is slowly moving forward
according to nevada health response
vaccinations in nevada currently stand
at 1.6 million that basically means that
these are the folks that have initially
initiated the process now 1.4 million of
those have actually completed the entire
process but breaking it down here more
for you locally we're talking about the
percentage in clark county that is
vaccinated that's 63 percent of the
population currently and breaking those
numbers even more for you we know that
women make up about 52 percent and men
breaking it down to about 47
now breaking it down even more
on those numbers residents between the
ages of 40 to 59 have the highest
numbers of vaccinations we see 15
between 40 to 49 and 16
of those ages 50 to 59 now when it comes
to the younger population those ages 10
to 19 that are fully vaccinated they
only make up 9
and we have to remember that it's only
those teens that are ages 12 and older
who recently got approved so obviously
that number is going to go up very
quickly now breaking down even more when
it comes to race and ethnicity white
americans are leading with an overall 40
percent that counts for about 49 of the
total population hispanics making up
about 26 percent now they make up about
30 percent of the total population here
locally moving on to our asian pacific
islanders they make up about 10 percent
right now they make up about 9.9 of the
total population and they're the
basically the best group right now that
is actually doing and outpacing everyone
else finally the black community
reporting only about six percent they
make up about eight point nine percent
of the total population here locally now
you can see the large gap among these
communities which is why health
officials keep enforcing the vaccination
campaigns within these neighborhoods
check out eightnewsnow.com so you can
schedule your appointment christian
casadas 8 news now